ladies and gentlemen welcome back the bullet
open championship is gonna be amazing you know
it's gonna be amazing because i have the best
commentator in the abyss don't tell robert has
i'm joined by grand master maurice ashley
how you feeling today man i'm feeling good
i'm feeling good yesterday was so dynamic it was
just incredible watching these bullet players show
their stuff and now we get to see the best
of the best in prime time this has got to
be awesome incredible chess we're going to see
today absolutely we got a amazing lineup that
we're going to talk about right now but first of
all let's take a look at the format because it's
going to be a very interesting format it's going
to be two hours of non-stop passion bullet fashion
for my end it's going to be a 12 player bracket
will show the players in a bit each side seated
one to six uh the time control obviously bulbar
is going to be a countdown maurice 15 minutes
ticking down we've discussed this also yesterday
are players going to approach this are we going to
stall or we're going to do something uh let's hope
there's a tie break because i love some deaths
and the winner will go to next year bullet
chess championship and look at these prizes
5k a winner walks out with today that's a nice
little cha-ching for a couple of hours work to
put into the bank account no question and 2k for
second place but nobody wants no stinking second
these players are in it to win it so it should
be an absolutely mind-bending day as the moves
are going to just come fast and furious absolutely
and maurice you know these players you know a lot
of these players um who do you think is going to
take this one home in your in your humble opinion
do you have any idea are you talking about the
whole thing oh yeah the whole thing i mean i'd
be an idiot to bet against hikaru nakamura i
mean come on this guy is just a bullet king
even with players who are higher rated than
him in bullet because they live for it they're
specialists you know you got your your your andrew
tangs out there you got your daniel naraditki's
who's certainly going to give him a run for the
money but there's something about hikaru when
the pain is on the line when the money money's
on the line when it's time to really deliver
he just seems to do it every single time so my
bet especially the way he qualified yesterday
my money is on hikaru absolutely and he does have
a very tough bracket i would say the left bracket
is uh covered on the right side we've got heavy
haters like icaru nakamura daniel neriditsky uh
federsif artemyev who is a blitz and bullet
specialist of jeffrey zhang it's just a
tough place to go through it is indeed the thing
about hikaru is everything to me depends on how he
starts if he gets through the first player then
he just starts to just rack up the wins he's a
momentum player if he wins one he wins and he wins
again and he just doesn't stop he has that killer
instinct that you see time and time again so it's
all about the start i think if a car gets knocked
out it's in the very first round that he plays
after that it's going to be deadly on whoever
he plays because he's just such a monster but he's
going to have competition paradiski for example is
certainly a beast jeffrey zhang is quite strong
and andrew tang like i said those are going to
be the favorites and of course alireza farouza
when he's on he's dynamic and i'm sure he has
his fans out there saying maurice don't sleep
on the young g he's going to get it done too
absolutely and let's look at the uh the pairings
right now for the first bracket that we have going
on we got uh vladimir putin furthest artemis
we're gonna do a little bit of a prediction
with jeffrey shang versus la tuan min jose
martinez versus michola bortnick and aryan
arigazi versus brandon jacobson now i know all
these players except brandon jacobson give me
a little bit of a of a backstory maurice who is
what kind of player is he brendan's a young g he
played in the u.s junior championship he's a very
good player uh no question about it up and coming
so when you got the young juniors you know that's
what they live for the speed they live for bullet
they want to show their quickness so don't sleep
on him although i think he's going to have a hard
road to hold when you look at all those serious
gangsters in the field i also want to point out
it's really unlucky that the two russians have
to play each other in the first matchup you know
they will be like oh come on there's a fix on
what's the conspiracy that was knocked out early
well just the way the numbers go you can't help
it you know just just the way the math works
so for them i'm sure for to say of an artemia
they've played each other many times and we'll
be teaming with each other many times as well well
somebody's going to get bragging rights a risky is
going home and one's moving on after this round
absolutely when they're going to the olympiad
2021 they're going to say are the mayor federic
who's going to be the board free i'm going to say
you can put fertilization board 4 because i own
them in bullets so i have that pass so there's
a lot of the line here by the way olympia
2022 since 2021 has actually been cancelled
and we're doing it in moscow in 2022 but yeah
it's going to be in their home country in their
home capital so let's see who gets bragging
rights today absolutely and i want to point
out uh the second one jeffrey shank versus
latuan man obviously jeffrey song is one of the
prodigies when it comes to u.s chess i think
he hit 2700 i'm not sure if he's still there
uh look for him yes absolutely entrenched
entrenched in 2700 land oh he's there perfect
perfect but maine however um during the sec
invitational he almost bit he almost defeated duda
young christopher duda almost lost to our
wonderful i am so he is definitely a force to be
reckoned with jose martinez and ward nick i will
take it to bortnick i think gording is more of
a bullet specialist and i want to see brandon go
through you know i want to see an american clash
in the finals which is going to be hikaru
versus brandon that's my prediction
i mean if you said hikaru versus andrew tang then
yeah that's the most likely american match-up
that we're going to see hikara versus andrew
andrew tanks a beast ebola did you see what he did
yesterday i mean i know you did because we were
calling it losing the not making it to the finals
uh not making it to today after the first
tournament and he said you know what that's it
i can't believe i didn't make it to the top six
i'm gonna eat everybody's lunch in this second
qualifier and he just went right through and was
number one so that's why he is already seeded into
the quarterfinals andrew tang will be a force to
be reckoned with and the matchup you really want
to see is tang vs alareza that is going to be
something special to watch i really want to see
the favorites go through to be honest to watch the
top seeds make it would be incredible and on the
on the other side with ikaru jeffrey
and nareditsky there's going to be an
all-american matchup there for sure i mean going
at least well we say for sure but almost certainly
we're going to see an american matchup on that
side if ikaru makes it through uh with jeffrey and
naradicki sitting there pretty so that should be
something uh really fascinating to watch as well
absolutely and for those who think i made it to
the preliminaries we got the cash uh i have to
be unfortunate you don't get any cash just yet
it's for only for getting into the quarterfinals
so andrew tang ferocia daniel and nakamura
already got nice little 250 you know a nice
little exchange things but they're gonna go for
the semifinals and they're gonna go for a big gun
so we're waiting for the games to start everyone's
getting settled everyone's getting ready
uh and i'm just if i may sorry interrupt but
that's a good point you know you win you win your
your section you come in first or second and
you got a 250 bucks i mean the people who did
it in one tournament that was for an hour
of work 250 an hour that's not a bad rate
to just be sitting around whipping out chess moves
that's pretty good that's pretty good and if you
make it any further hey kaching a thousand dollars
for a couple of hours hey that's not bad loot i
think a lot of our fans out there be like i'll
take that i'll take that and i'll be saying
the same thing give me that give me that and for
playing chess for playing bullet are you serious
come on now that's ridiculous that's like those
guys making big dollars playing video games i mean
it is actually yeah what a life is really good
yeah you sit back and you make a few hundred
maybe a thousand maybe two maybe five and and
you're sitting at home and then you could just
go to go hang out later with your friends and
say yeah i just i got i got the tab i got it
what did you do this evening i worked hard
and that's the thing you know i've been i've
been watching the u.s chess champs uh i watched
christopher you unfortunately lose in the finals
against alex on his birthday on his birthday with
a mouse slip that was uh that was the rough he was
busted he was busted he was busted already but you
never know it went from minus two to minus six so
that's that is the thirty but what we did see was
uh the entire thing was 90 minutes plus 30 seconds
people sweat they take four to five hours and
now they can be done in 10 minutes and boom
in 15 minutes chad there's a 15 minute countdown
in 15 minutes they can already earn 250.
we're already through there that is that is crazy
i really love this format i don't know how it's
gonna work out with the sec countdown without
increments so we're gonna i'm going to expect
a lot of fire we won't have player camps for the
first round but after this for the quarterfinals
we get to see the players antagonizing faces if
i can say so we want to see the emotions you know
you see our faces when a blunder happens and we
go ballistic like what the heck watch when these
players blunder in critical moments you're going
to see a lot of emotion come out hikaru normally
pulls quite a few faces i want to see some
of the other players just just be devastated
after a loss and be exhilarated after a victory
the more passionate chess i think the better
absolutely you don't really get to see the passion
over the board because people are tend to like
calm down there are other players in the
room so you can't really freak out even
though it does happen we do have stories about
people freaking out in chess rooms which i love
uh but if you're you're in the comfort of
your home so you're more inclined to just
break a mouse well let's not
do that but yeah let's see it
oops unfortunate i can't continue because i
don't have a no use the track pad buddy boy you
know this should be really funny to see something
like that but i would love to see some emotional
uh reaction somebody jump out of a
chair or like yeah look what i did
they flipped their entire table it just that
that that that would make uh that that would
definitely uh go viral without any question about
it so question for you maurice when did you have
the biggest when were you like the most exuberant
when you won a chess game can you remember
what's the most like final thing where
you're like that was a great moment
and i really wanted to scream it out or
you did scream it out but you couldn't
my most exhilarating moment ever was when i
made my final gm norm to be honest that was
a big moment i've been trying for several years
to do it i did it in new york city my home city
after traveling the world to try to do it i
finally actually did it at home i defeated
adrian neglescu in round eight of the
tournament the manhattan invitational
and he didn't even know that if i won the game
i would get my norm my title my final norm in
the title yeah so when i finished when the game
was over he resigned the smile on my face lit
up the room and he looked at me and he said
he's like why are you so happy you know right
you just see it like you just won a chess game
why are you so happy and i said that was my
last norm and he was shocked and then he's
like congratulations and i remember walking
outside it was march the 14th 1999 walked outside
it was snowing and snow i'm not a snow fan i'm not
a cold fan but the snow never looked so beautiful
it was like winter wonderland it was just like
snow it's like it's a magical moment it wasn't
christmas but it was like a christmas miracle
man it was an amazing moment in my life never
forget that night you were this close to making
a show snow angel just jumping in there make
a snow ancient just let it all in no that was
getting gentle boy doesn't do snow angels but
yeah that was definitely it was a moment to do
it that would have been the moment absolutely
oh that's beautiful i can't really so that's
the thing i can't really say it because i haven't
really achieved that much in chess just yet but
we're gonna get there uh my favorite moment in
that was i was playing a 2250 over the board
and so i was at the moment i didn't have a
feeder rating so i was like you know this
guy he's nothing and he was having a very complex
position he was like positioning everything he was
always like rubbing his hands you know cracking
his neck he was feeling really good and then he
made a move where he thought he had me and
he was ready to get up at that exact moment
i made like an intermesso hit the
clock and i got up and he was like
oh you gotta love those yeah yeah yeah yeah i
didn't do but i was close i was close parents
uh that's right the game now sit down exactly be
humble the games have started so let's see all
right let's go let's go and we got jose martinez
on the board right now against bortnick and we're
going to watch the clocks ending pause any pause
is going to be an important moment and you see
the players just blitzing out all the opening
moves right now white has a little bit of space
but black has broken with e5 and certainly looks
like he's equalized the game for the active pieces
absolutely but you know these open files work on
d1 rook and e1 i think white does have a very nice
small edge if it's actually gets the bishop
to c4 get this knight here get this bishop
off there is a pin you know there are a lot of
crazy ideas easier to play for whites maybe so
i think the problem for black is where exactly
to put all the pieces right so that to me is is
the biggest challenge but then again black is so
centralized that i just don't feel as though it's
that much trouble b5 a big break a big break
weakening his own position in order to get that
break that c5 pawn could become weak long term
and i think though the problem is you might need
a tricky solution maybe bishop takes on c3 was
the right way to play but he didn't have time to
look at it so he's just blitzing out the moves now
this exchange white is for choice with the pawn on
d6 this is gonna be problematic and what's this b5
that's just that looked like a gift of a pawn but
he didn't take it i'm not sure what was going on
there and now he's taking it what was the problem
before there was no problem before white is up a
clear passport now the question is can he break
the blockaders bishop f1 to avoid all tricks
right now he's just trying to make sure there
are no tricks because he hasn't seen the solution
yet i would have put a bishop on c7 seconds a long
time ago only 10 seconds left against 15 seconds
there is not a lot of time left he's trying to
exchange the queens which will happen this pawn
is not going to fall with bishop yeah bishop b5
by the way would have been an interesting
line and now both of them are just blitzing
out moves they're under 10 seconds a nice check
wins and now white is up a piece but can he win
as they're blitzing down with only seconds left
you're gonna move man you gotta move you gotta
move all they can do is just make moves bishop
makes three wins a rook he's gonna take in the
room you're gonna take it for free he missed it is
back in business oh black lost on time wow that's
what we're going to see a lot of today folks heart
palpitations that was just game one that was just
part of palpitations there were so many
missed moves there absolutely and we see
this game we switch over to brandon jacobson a
much more right position your black is up upon
legs and pawn has centralized
pieces this should be
a draw with perfect play i would almost say but
this is bullets there's not going to be a draw
here maurice i don't think there's going to be
a draw with 38 seconds left for black as black
is saying i'm up a pawn i'm going to torture you
i got a rook sitting on a beautiful square your
rook is passive i'm going to be able to bring my
king up as well i would play e i was about to say
i play e4 drop the rook on e3 and pick off
the pawn well now he can do it rookie three
take a pawn and this position is just dominant
for black oh my goodness king e3 looks great
because king e3 and f3 would have been absolutely
flavorful but look at those weak pawns that white
has he's desperate he's desperate black
with 25 seconds and bullet that's a year
absolutely no he's got to hide behind the pawns
but that shouldn't be that shooting probably
there are no checks he's got four of them back
the rook up and just start pushing baby the rook
is dead just keep pushing pawns just keep pushing
easy peasy uh this you gotta move the rook behind
another pawn and oh he he played that wrong he
didn't have to play that discovery but he was true
that he did win are we going to see the scores
updated because we're not seeing an update and
i was just just about to mention that let me
make sure that they are getting updated there
we go we see aryan getting up 2-0 against bret
and jacobson uh but let's let's take a look at
the rushing clash uh what's going on right now
vladimir furthest fader cf hard to tell this
position is certainly uh a challenging one it
looks just about a little bit better for black
because of his activity but white has a pawn oh
wait a minute that that a pawn is oh he's gonna
run he completely overlooked the apon and now he's
in big trouble just trying to check oh he hung me
what a steal are timmy and stole that one
let me go back to the real quick look at that
oh my god and he didn't yeah he could have
that's right he just walked he literally
walked into it this is what happened he
walked into it and set up his own mate
suicide he should have backed his king up one one
quick check and then get well then you still lose
the queen you just one big back run away but that
that's bullets for you that's crazy let's go back
to d he made that position but for a draw but he
didn't see the mate at all he just hung the mate
absolutely do you think he saw the mate it
was just a lucky one and jeffrey john lost
he went up 1-0 and then lost and and by the
way jose martinez came back with a win only
one matchup so far with a big lead is the one with
brandon uh losing right now to arjun so that one
he's got us he's got to win it gotta quickly try
to win this position looks dominant for black
right now black is just for choice big time he's
gonna grab the stuff and he has like you said a
year ago and this is the problem the when he
hung mate we we have this saying i remember
vinnie livermore in washington square park one of
the great hustlers of all time uh he was featured
in the movie searching for bobby fischer and
vinnie livermore after you blundered like that
in a game he would say one is good for two one
is good for two it means you you lost one game
it means you're gonna lose another one because
you just blundered so badly right now it's the
technique is not really perfect what i'm looking
at as far as black's concern but he is up a piece
for the moment he's trying to organize his forces
properly and not let this eep on white's hope of
all hope push this epon down the board but it's
not looking great as far as the technical side is
for black at the moment i don't know i don't know
it's really easy to play for white because the
king is completely cut off you can always throw
in a quick check a quick jab like you said uh
and just run around with the king this king could
go all the way to f5 really easy this should be
i'm gonna call as a win for white it's easier to
play for white well the bigger point is the time
eight seconds left seven seconds none this is
now an issue black can't figure out the perfect
coordination for his pieces the king is hiding
well but he can't figure out how to use the pieces
he's got to coordinate and they're just going
down at three seconds five seconds and oh he goes
he had ample opportunity there and instead didn't
handle it well in the time pressure that was a big
big win for fedex a big win it was just the fact
that the king was cut off it's easier to give
checks you can run away but it's we're already
halfway there the time is flying let's look at a
bridge generation down 3-0 let's look let's keep
on this game and then move on to the other one
um pretty yeah this this matchup is going
to go back and forth they may be friends i
don't know if they're friends and buddies
but hey this is the championship they're
playing for and that pawn on c4 is under
heavy fire right now how to defend it f4 f6
that's a bold move saying i want your pawn give it
to me there's a nasty looking pin but he couldn't
take advantage of it and now i don't know why
rook c don't queen b3 that's the problem queen b3
what look how he's handling his business i would
move my king at some point just off the line if
i were black just to get the king out of there
because that that attack on the king side is
starting to get a little bothersome all right the
other king just moved but here's that five and
white oh that's a big one i just didn't like this
and then it happened and suddenly black has to
give a pause on the position look how long he's
taking in a bullet game he sacked the exchange
but this is terrible this is stuck awful awful no
i agree if the rook is going to swing over it's
likely giving more room maybe even rook to d6 we
can get a date that maybe it was necessary to get
it decided to trade queens give up the exchange
in this position but this looks awful check and
now pawn on e7 you've got to go stop it king of
seven is forced and now the knight is trapped
isn't the knight trapped he could just win it
rook you're correct this doesn't care doesn't
matter he's carried out he let the knight dance
out into the game and his rook is hanging and
now a check and black is fighting white might
be winning but black is creating counter play
it should be easier to play for black once he
gets e7 pawn there should be a lot of checks
that like you said the knights are very tricky
make sure they put your knight two points right
he trades everything off and this shirt it's only
a drawer and now it's only a draw oh he blundered
opposition can he pull it off can he pull it off
should have enough time let's see the technique
and he just needs to bring his queen back now
bring his king up and that's all she's going
to be right but let's see what's going on five
no stalemate that's the only problem but two
seconds left this is ample time queen what
are you doing what are you waiting on queen
e2 you want it you want it it's fine you went
for the checks it didn't go for the match
you're right you're right there's no time there's
no time palpitations man um okay jose martinez
against bortnick the store is now three one
for boarding he's definitely a hybrid favorite
with only five minutes left with brandon jacobson
he's down five oh your prediction remind me never
to take your stock picks never because you said
brandon might make it an all-american final
oh he you know that's the thing when you start
losing games in bullet your confidence goes down
and you could just lose every single game and
that's what's happening he's not this bad he
got here for a reason but when you start losing
games the tilt factor comes in and to overcome
tilt is extremely difficult so poor brandon right
now down five nothing but in the meantime we have
a more competitive matchup here jose needs to win
this game oh right before rook g4 would have been
made in the mix would have been a cool one i'm
not gonna look at it okay rocket four finally
get the g pawn there he goes it's easier to
play for black i would say because he had all
these checks 17 seconds against 13 seconds like
white's a pawn though whoa whoa that's a decision
there why do you give away his a pawn i
don't know you should have doubled rooks
bad news and now you're just blitzing it out 11
seconds for white he's trying to make sure that he
doesn't lose some kind of technical way oh no oh
he dropped a rook beautiful play by black trying
to avoid and now the question can't trade rooks
he's got to keep playing now there is a tragedy
black mate with that much time on the
clock the answer is yes too much time
you're going to get married easily here it
comes over and then that's that's amazing
no problem checkmate with the two rooks beautiful
technique i actually i want to really mention that
he well never mind uh actually i will
really mention really quick he just had like
a very subtle in this position he just moved
his rook to f7 i'm gonna say i'm safe now
i'm gonna use this rook to harass your king and
start moving my palm that was like the momentum
very good technique in that position uh let's
look at brandon let's give him some let's give
some fight left let's see if we can get one win on
the camera but oh it's six oh i mean it's the pain
and also being broadcast as well that's the
worst part and you know people like you are
like let's give him some love he's thinking no
don't show up in this game please what are you
this is doing 6-0 you can't win a single game
i mean oh my goodness this is full-scale tilt
on the junior right now and his position as black
he's looking for some play but he's down a pawn
and it's two-pack well it's one passer and that
eight pawn is flying up the board he just took
that that looked like uh potential sacrifices
there but now he's at least one upon back but he's
in a wicked end game he had to give up a piece and
he's hoping to disrupt white's pawns on the king
side but that knight needs to get back in the game
somehow i'm not really sure how though the knight
is not well 98 wow nice move and he just took
the pawn but there is some play for black there
is absolutely can he make it problematic and oh
g5 that's a cute move ouch look at the h pawn run
and h6 is going h6 h7 h8 okay rook here oh my god
and now it's just bringing the knife back he's
already cut off and that's it that's all she wrote
eight seven oh argents 1 minute and 30 seconds
left let's go to jeffrey shang versus little
one they're 4-4 right now all the other games
are pretty much the side except the russian clash
let's see how this one's going to turn out that's
probably not decided and bortnick definitely going
to win that match up but right now jeffrey needs
to make sure he wins otherwise he's out white
needs to win this game and he's dominating right
now oh it is tight they are tied right now
so a draw is fine to go through some death
well therefore 59 seconds left um if he wants to
avoid the sudden that you're talking about yeah
and by the way knight e2 and now he's one upon
has has black he's up upon but that d-pawn is
so strong but what's the conversion what's this
yes 28 and the knight is on the d8 square that's
a lot that's a hard piece to lift queen of six
what did he do this for he just gave away a piece
wait hey six yeah the knight was hanging and now
he just needs to promote white is clearly winning
jeffrey has always go for f2 oh it doesn't matter
bishop g2 it's fine it's easy this is easy this
is there he goes now he just has to stall he just
has to stall now let's quickly look to the oh he
he still has to he still has to not lose the game
does jeffrey right because a new game the game
does count you're correct they're correct the
game counts and and a draw in that matchup with
only four seconds oh and they still got a game
oh demian would have won the match if he could
have kept it going but has a chance because
there was four seconds left and they started
again the match with arjun is over brandon lost
seven oh uh bortnick won five and a half so that's
done jeffrey's still in the middle of his game so
two games on fire right now and we're seeing the
russians who goes through artemia with the edge
he's got the white pieces a draw is enough but he
should know don't play for a draw when you need
a draw play for a win and let the other player
beg for the draw so we'll see if he can pull it
off with the white pieces right now absolutely
and also enough obviously another important match
is going on is jeffrey shang versus le toimen he
needs to win wonderful time needs to win so we're
also going to keep an eye on that but mainly on
this game let's see how this is going off uh right
now we don't want to switch too much with white
having a small edge on the queen side but not too
much i don't know you call it small by the way
bishop b5 there was crushing after c5 he missed
a winning move on the spot did artemyev but now
president won the game a beautiful position uh
again that bishop b5 was calling itself but look
at that last move the pieces are so dominant he's
not sure what to do though with the white pieces
here the the technique is escaping him his bishop
on c3 is the problem his bishop has no real future
so he's trying to figure it out isn't this false
i was about to say wasn't that hanging rook to
he wins a clean pawn this is desperation this is
all over this is all over people bishop takes and
now he's trying to defend he's trying to defend
but there goes another pawn biting the dust
and the oh he doesn't have enough on the draw he
needs to win all he's got is a draw a draw is all
that white knees white doesn't care you can check
him all day long he's got 19 seconds on the clock
black could not take it for pet
and here he goes he could just
why is he trying to mate just check just check
him just check him why did he do that i don't know
he just needed a draw he kept the game alive oh
we always bloated this what are you doing with
all the time on the clock he's lucky he's
still drawing he's lucky oh my god dude
oh my goodness that was crazy wonderful time
one so we have what happened here just really
lost yeah we're down to a sudden death
absolutely and special shout outs
well it's quick special shout out to brandon
jacobs who did get a win so it wasn't a quick edo
i don't know exactly the rules of sudden death uh
so let me ask my team uh real quick to see what's
going on we will go into a sudden death uh aryan
congratulations we have boardnick going through
and we have uh artemyev going through a set of
uh phantom savers a bit of an upset on my end
uh very well played and we're going to
see some death between jeffrey zhang
and just a wonderful time amazing uh yes indeed
jeffrey blew that jeffrey brew that big took it
over the game but we have time big time he
blew that one he was just well what can you
say what can you say you just all you need to
do is draw the game and you end up losing uh
not good that's a bad opening for wife this
is a bad very bad opening for white i mean
look at this nasty position he's down a pawn his
pieces were back okay burst off because here it is
really easy the first person to win moves on
it's that easy they can play a hundred games
doesn't matter bullet qualifier
bullet man tiebreaks are the best
and here we go blackish black has got a bad bishop
on c8 and we'll hope to somehow get that going at
some point why it will castle quickly and why will
a for some key square c5 looks like a nice square
for something to go to if a knife
only could get a knight to migrate
and i like what black is doing to be able to play
for the move bishop to a6 but he just hung up on
boom let me snatch that one off so he's down right
now that's a good start we could go in and jeffrey
this is over jeffrey is showing why he's 2700
and a brilliant bullet player as well and now
black is just desperate oh a knight mate threat
have seven don't touch my knight look at these
knights dominant there's no way to survive he'd
sack this queen and this is going to be all over
but the crying 35 seconds left for jeffrey he just
needs to play the right move why did he give away
an exchange there i have no idea that wasn't
necessary but he's just going to keep trading
pieces let's trade it down he's got a fast h pawn
and he's going to just push it and he's going
he's just going to go keep going keep going
forward it should be this should be an easy
win for white uh he also is ten seconds up of the
cup actually jeffrey's underrated queen b6 is boss
queen b6 is nasty actually again look at that
bishop it's devastating that bishop is going with
check and he's got 21 seconds this he can slow
play this he can slow play this one there's no
pass going for black that's the worst part black
has no counter play anywhere bishop a4 now bishop
a4 is coming bishop a4 at some point he's going
to move his king away and again check and he's
played bishop e2 but he could play bishop a4 and
the guy would have cried he's trying to go forward
but this is dead deadly too yeah that's back what
a mate that's wow game over jeffrey sneaks through
at the end wow wow congratulations jeffrey
what a game uh congrats like i said artemis
goes on to the next one i think the bracket is
updated it is updated let's show that real quick
we have hikaru nakamura versus vladislav art
of af jeffrey shang versus daniel naraditsky
that's going to be an american clash andrew
tang versus bordnick and aryan aragassi versus
aleurasia ferocia it's gonna be a rough game for
everyone good at competitions may i ask arjun is
from which country erika he's from india okay
so we got india the ukraine we've got russia
we've got the u.s u.s well represented on both
side of the bro wait a second are we saying that
a lot of american players are superficial because
they just like bullet because i see four americans
playing right here in this bracket half the field
as americans and then one of each country well
alareza right now looks undecided at the moment
as he he's playing under the fide flag i believe
wow these are gonna be big boss match-ups do you
see the players right now who are playing this
is going to be fierce bullet at its highest level
will be played and whoever wins this can say they
did something because this is going to be awesome
it's going to be a great great quarterfinals we're
gonna set everything from everyone we will be
back in about six to eight minutes and we will
show you the quarterfinals the board open
chess championship see you guys just a bit
so
and welcome back ladies and gentlemen the bullets
open championship with a man maurice ashley
maurice exciting games going well i'm glad we
had that break because my heart rate was going so
quick i might have to take medication to calm down
it was just so exciting so exhilarating just heart
pounding action and it's just going to get better
now as a few of the gangsters in bullet chess have
come into the play and this should just be
on as the best of the best have joined us
i mean it's just amazing absolutely and you're
mentioning gangster and what i also know is
that you do something on your twitch channel
gangster chess what is that exactly rules
gangsta chest just means that you go for blood
we don't want to see technical end games there's
no kappa blanca niceties karpov precision play
petrosian defense no no we only want to see people
get pounded we say hit him hard boom hit him again
that's the kind of games we go over in gangster
chess and there's no way in the world you're not
going to come away feeling like okay i'm ready to
beat all my friends after watching that kind of
play absolutely you got to get hyped exhilarated
as you mentioned beforehand we are no second
grade diligence when it comes to chess and we will
get gangster on you so make sure to show about
twitch.tv slash gm ashley's where you can find
them i believe monday wednesdays and fridays are
set yes indeed those are the three days i might
come on other days depending but those are the
days that i'll be on regularly perfect man perfect
make sure to follow him we have chescom chris in
the chat you know chess come chris he's a beast
shouting you out i'm also streaming twitch
tv slash bigfoot well it's all about maurice
today but it's not actually all modern recently
forget maurice it's about the players let's look
at the price really quick we got gangsters here
the bullet gangsters and look at these brackets
oh my goodness these are just nasty brackets you
could you could just call these you know in many
places especially our temmie of nakamura i'm going
to tell you that one's just sparkling in my eyes
it's like whoa we got to watch that a little
bit extra we want to give everybody love but
that one we're going to have to give a little bit
extra love because those two are some serious oh
geez well we got a young g in there as well as our
temmie if not so old but that's going to be a fun
matchup to watch absolutely we can actually look
at them right now the car streaming at the moment
as well he's calm he's cool collected with a 2k
cab i could see the pimples on his face look at
that oh he's he's a little nervous you see that
doing a little shuffle carver man this guy is
absolutely amazing his ability to play quickly and
talk he might be able to even type messages while
he's playing and talking and drinking some some
uh red bull i guess red bull is still a sponsor
of his the guys just got some some i i can't do
it you know i multitasking god is ikaru nakamura
absolutely and not only he's playing we have some
other huge players as well uh that we're gonna go
for for let's look at the prices real quick we
have some huge prizes as well first place 5k
going for the open second place 2k just replacing
second just for a few games it is amazing uh and
there are still some players joining chat so we
gotta keep our cool we gotta calm down the players
joining and we'll be starting very soon keep our
cool and calm down what are you talking about
this is the bullet open championship they would
fire us if we kept our cool and calm down can you
imagine trying to do a golf call while this is
going on no not going to happen we're going to
keep it busy keep it live keep it flavorful
because the players are going to move faster
than we can talk let's just be clear they're going
to be flying through the moves and we got to try
to keep up with them you're right you're right
you know how they urge it oh they're right listen
you're trying to write the chat i can't handle the
chat when they write they become figures monsters
um but we do have all the players in the cams
right now so it should be going well i'm gonna
fire up the players here and i see 1k for the
semifinal as well so everybody's got their 250.
that's okay that's all right but another 750
dollars for 15 minutes of play let's be real
that's like 15 minutes 750 every 15 minutes boy
you might be getting like jeff bezos money if
you could do that i think he might be making i
think he's making more than 750 every 15 minutes
that guy but still that's a nice chunk of
change to add with some quick bullet skills
you know when these guys were playing bullet
back in the day when carl was playing bullet
chest as a young man i'm talking about when he
was 10 11 12 years old could he have imagined
that those skills that we were just poo pooing
back in the day no that's not bullet what are
you doing you're just wasting your time all
day can could he have imagined that one day
in the in 2020 that he would be getting
paid kaching for what he just did
for fun just extraordinary the way the game
has evolved and having all these fans watching
and having fun just enjoying the greatness of
these players as well yeah absolutely i mean
i would have never imagined the the twitch
explosion obviously the chess explosion of
these days do give these formats a chance and
they are off by the facts actually let's look
at tikaru right now against artemis
let's see uh how he's doing over here
yes indeed we missed some of the opening right
here but it's all right because it looks as though
white is trying to do some damage on the queen
side the move a6 will come at some point to make
that b-pawn work but black just played an amazing
knight c5 and won an exchange but the white knight
on c5 maybe hikaru intentionally dropped the
exchange i mean this is this isn't karu's skill
somehow you know yeah it looks like i was making
a mistake but no oh no did he just blunder a mate
did he actually getting his one boy and he's in
big trouble because that king is under a heavy
attack he just played check but he could not take
the rook it looks like he's going to get mated
and this check that's that's only a draw now that
last move art i don't i don't like it oh no he's
blunder to me he's walked into it his king is in
deep trouble and he knows it this but but i'm not
sure yes there it is there it is he's just dropped
this queen no but he look at this what's going on
is this real is this real he got his queen back
he got his queen back it's insane he's winning now
how does hikaru do this this is unbelievable
he actually won a game that he was getting
mated and artemy went for the queen instead of
mating and ikaru pulled it off i i can't believe
what i just saw that is nice i literally
cannot believe what i just that's not fair
it's just not fair how does he do that he was i
saw the bar going up and down left and right it
was jumping at me from the screen but i don't even
time to look at that game let's look at this game
what is happening on the h file uh i think artemis
cannot believe he just lost the game he just lost
and he is in big trouble it's not about the
age file it's about the psychology of the
moment right now he's in big trouble for losing
the game he just lost to hikaru when he was
mating that king i'm sure there was a mate
in there somewhere and he blew it and now
he's got to somehow get his head wrapped tight
because if he lets hikaru win another game we
know how the the guy works he'll win every game
game after game after game he just he'll just
punish you and that's what he's facing right now
psychologically is artemy event all of them in the
world know it including magnus that when you're
playing antsy karu look at this e4 hitting the
queen if you play knight d4 c5 is coming i mean
this is just awful this is just awful c5 gift me
the piece hello that's it give me the piece just
take it just take it that's a piece that's it
no problem everybody's connected queen bishop
brook everybody's connected and black's winning
that game hicarro already up two-nothing
by the way jeffrey has taken a 2-0 lead in
his match-up against naraditsky that's
a big deal that is a big deal already
wait can you turn off the moon only actually
absolutely yeah actually winning again against
mikula boarding they stayed on this game for a
little while honestly andrew 10 congratulations
with your uh signature to cloud9 now even esports
like this it is amazing and he's playing some
fantastic bullets you can ask them if it's allowed
but i don't see why it shouldn't be allowed
anyways i'm not going to read shot
during the games i will have self-control
okay g3 i want to play g5 and fork him but
first let's not let him take the knight
maybe knight h5
actually let's just trade
i'm not sure about this
at least it should be fine
i'll just trade off the rick or not this
rook is very close to getting trapped though
not totally sure what i'm doing here
yeah bonds are rushing white is doing
oh but bishop c6 kind of locks it out
beautiful light square bishop taking
everything he's going to keep that on and
9 seconds against 50 seconds
this could be black screen
i'm playing way too slowly
that's way too much hesitation
it is going to be over and while we look at
this game let's look at the other game as well
talent that we have going on here is ali
raider surfer russia against aryan erigasi and
rio um i'm not surprised maurice he is a beast
hmm
to come back yeah perfect no you're absolutely
correct it's gonna be monumentally hard to come
back in here but aryan does have some time left
seven minutes on the clock so it is possible
but he needs to win this one he does
need to win and right now he's he's
not looking good here and after knight takes on
that four knight e2 check oh sorry i thought it
was a check but instead it's really just a loss
of an exchange and now trading down is alireza
and showing his technique here there is no
chance for white zero zilch he's out four zero
we could we can chalk this match up almost a
hundred percent to alareza i didn't see an update
in the score there i thought it was going to go to
4-0 but it is now yeah and that's that and hikaru
also up four zero momentum just we
walked we look at jeffrey shaking
you see him shaking his head you see him shaking
he said there what did i say momentum momentum
momentum daniel has won four in a row if my count
is correct because i remember jeffrey being up 2-0
and this was getting worse and worse that match
is looking really bad meantime we have two matches
that are basically over ikaru and alareza should
go through which which is going to be great for
the fans i think the only match up that is really
actually all of them are really powerful right now
andrew tang daniel naraditsky up two games they
just have to keep their cool can jeffrey keep
his cool right now yeah absolutely is he gonna
keep school this is a very important game he is
oh no forget about keeping your pool he's
blundering every single game now every single game
and it looks like this one is going to be over
plus three will be impossible to come back from
with only six minutes left on the
clock six minutes is three games
right there's no increment six minutes is three
games so all narrative gets to do is draw what
all he has to do draw one of the next games we're
going to count down a draw wins it ikaru it's over
let's have a quick look and won a game bortnick
won a game and he is inspect that is indeed
a contestable match let's look at that game i i
think that is what we should be looking at let's
jump over to andrew thing and board nick there we
go we have entertainment only sequence and andrew
not enough of a lead to be safe and here bortnik
just played a nice night move and then backed up
i don't understand why and now putting the
knight back on what square it really belongs
on absolutely this is my last move by the bishop
that bishop is such a woeful piece you don't even
touch it like you do whatever you like with it i'm
not going to bother it i'm just going to figure
out a plan in this position it looks like e6 was a
good move earlier when the bishop was wayward but
now the bishop is going to sit exactly where it
is and white can't figure out what to do despite
having 24 seconds on his clock now e6 there
you go there we go that was the breakup you got
a boss position with an f5 move you can't touch
that and then now the rook to the h-bot if he can
get it there he needs a rook to get to the h-file
somehow black saw it coming and forced him to go
over the knight having to drop back i don't like
that what is happening 54. you got to watch for d4
but now the pawn is dropping and white still has
great play here nice technique kappa blanca esque
technique with that a3 move by the way i like
putting everything on dark squares but is he
winning why no he's gonna lose a piece of peace
oh no my goodness he just blundered the piece
and the pawn is going through andrews he played
keep playing tenacious defense that was awful
why is he resigned there it's four seconds
against four seconds you gotta have to try there
that was heartbreaking that's the end of the
match that's the end of the match that game
costing it's over it's over meantime both ikaru
and alareza have their opponents on full tilt 5-0
in that match uh daniel just won his game against
is that six in a row he won against jeffrey brown
that's over rover the only matchup that matters
is this one andrew just needs we don't need to
watch these these are these are bloody every
there's there's bleeding going on we don't want
it to work says no this is the one that matters
i think competitive as andrew tang needs a draw
only to guarantee the win so let's see
this game draw by what oh yeah yeah i think
i mean look at those knights look at the rooks on
the file this is horrible this is just terrible
completely for black to have to play and
especially when you need a win can he get a
lead on the clock he doesn't even have that he
could have taken it i think it was just a uh a
little jab it doesn't matter it's like it doesn't
matter it's all white needs white has definitely
not played this well i will say that white has not
played as well to this point white has given black
too many chances why do you trade queens though
that's an odd thing to do in this one what's the
last thing yeah that wasn't a chance on beat three
but he doesn't he got nothing he got nothing zero
zilch soccer fair it's an equal position and
equal positions tend to be flag fest he just
needs to play fest if he wins this game he still
has an opportunity but he needs to win this game
or else it's going to go out of his hands all
right i like what he's doing on the king side
although i would have rather to have a pawn on
h4 than this structure but what is what a bold
player andrew is to put his king in this position
and now it's all about the past pawn the black's
pawn is very strong but he just made the king of
the board there's no way to bring the king back
uh in time the black king white pawn will
queen this is a draw now it's a win for white
technical win destroys all he needs so he just
took the rook and ended it now not enough time
if he just lasts a couple of well if there is
enough time if he wins this one he just has to
not hang mate exactly that's it just not hang mate
quickly uh so you're right if he wins this game
quickly he has to win it quickly there's no way
it's going to happen four minutes with him no
i don't think it's going to happen but i do like
myself a uh the possibility for sound death let's
see how it's going to go out daniel there at 61.
eighth in a row is now the what a beast eleration
ferocious seven wins uh andrew tang is the only
one that matters at the moment for the standing so
let's see how that's going to work out knight to
b3 it's not something you'd like to see with white
no it's not and that lets us trade off all the
buttons and uh that's going to be all she wrote
in this position i like the dark square bishop but
i don't like losing pawns bleeding pawns and being
down in exchange i mean is there a trick somewhere
he wants to get on the h5 you see that sneaky he's
trying to get on the h prop of the bishop on d4
but it it's not up that not quite working out
he's trying to stay busy he's trying to keep it
busy but look at this he just took the c3 pawn
and now he just took the e3 [ __ ] take it back oh
my god any chance that's it that's awesome a win
and it's over we have our four semi-finalists yeah
oh yeah they're going to play a last game but just
to point out real quick chat is in this position
you can't even take because you're going to lose
this rook with check so this one was all over and
there's only nine seconds left let's let's look at
let's have a quick look at daniel naraditsky
let's see how he's been faring at the end of
it it does seem like there's the ching ching
i'm not sure if you guys can hear that but
this should be a win whoa he gave away his bishop
for no reason and then he gave away his room
oh my god i mean when it rains it pours he won
a bishop and then instantly he gave back a rook
that's when your brain stops working that
that's just he was on such full tilt playing
a game all right it's going to be aborted
uh that's over eight two dominant match
they won by six alareza had the most dominant
result winning by seven and while at least his
opponent has a chance to to come maybe not maybe
win this game with i hope he draws at least but
this one he's losing i mean he's just losing oh
oh we might slip the frog he might win games and
and no he did not sorry i was wrong it was the
other way around and it was 8-0 so so actually
i was thinking that it was the other color but
it just was too much it's so basic ali raza up
8-0 and that's the most dominant result kairu
plus six naradiski has made it to plus seven
and andrew tang has gone through so we're just
playing right now guys we don't even have to
look at the rest these games don't mean anything
at all absolutely we can see who's going to move
forward who's gonna claim a nice little uh nice
little uh yeah how do you say that a nice little
payday that we got going on here for the quieter
finals they're going to move on g i mean you pick
up a grand uh we're playing some bullet 15 minutes
that's always nice yeah this doesn't uh it doesn't
sound too bad for me two of you are going to get a
thousand others are at least guaranteed a thousand
orthogonal going through so we're gonna have
some great they're gonna play this one out chat
doesn't matter too much because there is
draw and we've got the standings out there
which was incredibly amazing let's have a
quick look last time what the standings were
ikaro winning seven to one daniel oh they're
playing an ad on nicaragua's stream so let's
move back to the prizes uh i don't think the
bracket is updated just yet so we can't show that
for now but let's see how it is sorry carl winning
will move forward daniel erdicki so if he carved
versus daniel we will get andrew tang versus
ali raza that's gonna be a huge semi-final
well three out of four americans in the semi
so one will go on to the final for sure and
our prediction seems like it's going it's looks
is looking more and more like ikaru versus
andrew tang which would be a boss matchup
indeed incredible but it to me right now
actually any finals match up will be boss you can
just pick them just pick them anyone you say we're
going to have ali raza play naraditsky that's
a boss matchup any matchup right now would be
a boss matchup but i think that the favorites
all right akaru and andrew tang to get through
because they are supreme bullet specialists and
even though even though naradiski i think is even
higher rated than hikaru in bullet if i'm not
mistaken the live bullet ratings i think he's
actually higher rated but hikaru i mean it's
ikaru but hikaru knows he has his hands full
right now this is going to be a very difficult
matchup for him as his detanglers matchup as
well so we're going to see some good stuff if
anything we're going to see some great stuff
as you mentioned so we're going to hit a quick
break we're going to set everything up and then
we'll be back for the semi-finals build up
with championships see you guys just a bit
so
and we are back ladies and gentlemen we
have the semi-finals in front of us to go
start in just a minute i'm still
here i'm still that way there you go
see the camera has inverted so i don't know which
way to point but now i know uh maurice ashley
is still here he's also on twitch twitch to
visualize gm ashley make sure to go there every
gangster chess puzzles all the other stuff um i'm
a big fan i'm even a subscriber where where's my
fit patch oris that is what i'm asking we're
working on it we're working on it we're also
working on the emotes i try to upload the brand
new fresh emotes but twitch is it's a weekend
i don't know what they're doing on the weekend you
think we're working on the weekend why aren't they
working on the weekend so that i can be approved
so i can put those emotes up the subs want to
know where are their emotes so that and their
fit badges as well so that they can have some
fun during the chat we already have fun doing the
chat talking about all the stuff as you mentioned
gangster chess trivia puzzles news of the day
we do it we do it all we do it all on the show
and have fun doing it but look for
the emotes check me out follow me and
sub if you want to get the hot off the presses
emotes absolutely now let's focus our attention
back to the brackets finals we have hikaru
nakamura versus daniel nardinski i mean he
car is going to have difficult against daniel
because daniel always puts up a good fight but
i think he will win eventually andrew tank versus
roja i cannot predict a winner i don't know
what do you think no no there are no predictions
no this is going to be on like popcorn
no way in the world these players they're
getting psyched look at ikaru getting
pumped funny to see dania just lean back you
know like fat joe lean back he's like i'm just
gonna chill i don't care that i'm playing hikaru
nakamura i can handle this did i see him actually
even yawn there come on look at that okay let
me let me watch it let me show you real quick
all right it's out there incredible from
the young g's like i got this ain't no
they're both on the west coast right so what's
it's now 11 a.m that's pretty early for these
kind of players uh you know they like to wake up
late so maybe that's why he's still like trying
to get the the sleep from out of his eyes we'll
see but the other two players are definitely in
it right now absolutely so the games are going
to start in just a bit we'll be working in there
let's look at the uh qualifier knockout rules
again real quick can you take the chat through
with maurice what's going on well you know we
had we had the early brackets we had the early
brackets and then we have this time controller
15 minute countdown that's where they're going
right now with 15 minutes we see when you take a
lead the pressure is on one player goes up three
nothing it's probably over i know that sounds
crazy but it's probably over a three game lead
is enough even though it's bullet and it looks
as though we have started so let's get with that
but the winner of this will get to qualify for
next year's bullet just championship and a fat
5g as well that's absolutely well we're not
there yet this is still only the semifinals
we'll see who moves on to the final the finalists
are guaranteed at least two thousand dollars the
winner gets five thousand and here we see
andrew tang versus farouza out alareza you
know he's he's quick but andrew telling i'm
telling you he's mercurial i mean he's like
i i s when i watch him play he plays 30 30-second
chest to warm up for bullet i mean i've never seen
anybody play 30-second chess before he plays
30-second chess so he can warm up for bullets
so to him it's like you give me double the time
that's what are you kidding me that's forever ever
like just as too much and already for ruger
with this queen h4 excursion as stolen apart
boom stolen upon thank you and showing his skills
and still has 30 seconds left on the clock look
at that knight on e5 that knight is a beast that
knight will never be chased trading off queens
locking down the queen side and now it's time to
work on the king side of the board and he's just
going to play it slow he's got this technically
this is over everybody going to the dark squares
look at that bishop it's anemic the bishop is ugly
trade off more and more the more the marion here
comes the king now is the king's turn i'm going to
look for an h6 a g5 and an f4 and chase you back
you're going to go backwards son oh look at this
technique man i think he's going to have the point
he said that's it let's get out of here i'm
going to lose that game the guy's just too good
amazing and that's a good gotta talk about that
real quick that's a really good strategy if you
think there's only 15 minutes if you think
you're going to lose move over to the next
game especially at the starting fifth because you
need to wreck those wins up and you cannot draw
out losing games beautiful point beautiful point
he resigned somebody might say he resigned early
but the guy had so much time in the clock
in the wind was so straightforward for these
players at this level that it didn't make sense at
all for him to keep playing stop the game go on to
the next one you're gonna lose play the odds and
that's exactly what he did that's why these guys
are so good not just add bullet but at strategy
as well match strategy and that's what happened
there and we see yet another game where he could
uh be in some trouble andrew tang even though he's
got the two bishops but the the c file in that
pawn especially on c7 is causing him a world
of trouble so at the moment alareza up 1-0 this
is a crucial game folks a crucial game and now
again the control of the c5 score but i like
the way black has handled this because he's
pushed wide backwards and he's broken the bind
he's broken the bind on the c5 square but he's
standing at a cost he's done under the cost of
the f6 square broke the bind on one side but now
he's seen a breakthrough on the other and alarisa
how he's playing this is going to be over rupert
wants an idea in both of them he's like gm
chess you understand what i'm saying to you
he's playing like he's playing against magnus
and naca at the high level he wins again
gm chest in bullet it's incredible to watch
this kind of beautiful display of technique
by ali raise up two nothing let's see the other
matchup though right now 100 agree karu is up
one nothing so ikaru doing his thing in this
one actually he's up two nothing as well
we're seeing we're seeing some great play by
players at the high level players who are used
to playing at a high level what i'm seeing right
now is actually not just bullet ability but also
straight chest strength these are players who
are much higher rated from a chess strength
standpoint you might be fast but i play better
chess let me point out one thing maurice let me
point out one thing what happened last time
when daniel was down 2-0 yes but you know
this but this is the kara nakamura we're talking
about like what i like to say is chest strength
does matter although it looks like a blunder on
hikaru's part it looks like he just blew something
what yes no what's the move why did he take on a5
i don't know why he didn't take on a5 there seemed
to be some sacrifices available he was gonna take
it on a5 and threatened queen a2 queen 82 and
once again the mistakes are creeping in this
is this was a very good position for black
but somehow now it looks like hikaru has played
great defense and i don't understand why am i
blind at 85 look like it was hanging at some
point now hikaru looks to be in total control
of this position and he just has to get on his
high horse oh six seconds and okay this is still
a little bit of danger he took it take it
on a2 and he's back in the game is black
black is back in the game he's getting
later there we go we moved and now it is
wow crazy that was crazy and
ikaru's cussing right now
with what just happened in that game oh my
goodness crazy chest we're seeing but a two-point
lead for ikaru with nine minutes left plenty
of time but dania has to start winning games
he's got to start winning games and i'm not
seeing a move right now what is happening is it
frozen i see the clocks the clocks are strong
oh no no no no that's that's that is correct
here we go we got them back up all right yeah
because no way they're going to be sitting
on the thing for that long you're correct
there is a little bit of jerkiness going on
like what's this wow what an interesting
mean sack by hikaru why would you do that
i mean this looks terrible this that was my
that was maya maurice i i've been told that
i misspelled nakamura's name so we had to uh
where to fix that real quick we can't have that
on stream of course but let's go back to nakamura
by the way nakamura's getting toasted here toasted
like absolutely he almost hung mate in that
position in the a pawn look at that bishop on h8
when do you see nakamura have a bishop like this
oh my god it is time to give up this game this one
is over oh and he dropped his queen as well after
knight to e7 so uh is he still playing he's still
playing that is he's using the strategy of your
peculiar playing let the time pass as much as
possible that the guy made you uh but because
you're up and yeah so just wasting more time
on the clock he's going to let his time run out
and dania's laughing like come on man come on man
come on i want to fight nine already this ain't
right he let his time run all the way down
because he's got a slight lead putting more
pressure on his opponent to win games within
the time frame so this game now daniel's got one
back that's cool for him he's going to look to see
what he can do to even the match by the way in the
other matchup andrew tang also won a game to make
this one competitive as well so it's gonna be a
very tight one we're gonna look at this game after
we watch this game don't wanna hop too much let's
look at this one right now with nakamura having
a very nice e file it looks like he does have
the position under control beautiful center um
it's going to be hard for daniel to put to punch
through here but i don't like why the garbage is
that happen after knight takes on e5 that the file
shut down shut him down and now all of a sudden
it is wait wait why do you allow ec it's like a
little e6 action why why would you allow e6 why
would you allow yourself at the group with the
position open and clean it for a check and that
excursion by your bishop oops i don't know why
you take your bishop away you got to understand
and keep the game tight you want to keep the game
tight and now he's dropping in exchange as well
that that was really bad on his part so move to
go after an a pawn and a lot of the breakthrough
with e6 was was not high level that was really bad
on dania's part and now he's down two points yet
again two games and he's in desperate desperate
situation and by the way we're back to this match
it looks like alexa also won struck back and he's
up two so our prediction is looking bad right now
hikaru yes but not andrew tang as well the
stronger players are proving themselves these
are the stronger chess players are proving that
yeah you might be good in bullet but i am going
to put the weight of my ability on your neck and
make you try to figure this out what just happened
whoa what happened there there was a trick there
we're going to look at that it was just a trait of
queens but at the moment white is for choice white
is just taking a piece and now another piece and
now another pawn and white it looks like trading
down and at the end of it he's able to pick off
a pawn but that seaport is strong that sea pawn
is going down the board yeah looks back and now
the king will come up over and there's no way
for the c pawn to advance here comes the white
king so that's going to be okay this looks like
maximum draw for black but he's worried about it
about his c pawn as white can't figure out a way
to attack it though why can't figure out a way to
attack it if white plays rook eight three and and
then moves over to a2 he will not win the pawn oh
he's gonna play it out but now he's playing the
ball he's gonna go for the he's gonna go for the
for the flag that's all that razor does he knows
this is a drawn position he knows he can't really
make any progress we're going to go for the flag
but but he's lost black is lost in this position
white is winning this position no doubt about
it i don't know why i didn't play king g5 there
but this is a winning position for white this is
over okay moving the king back and forth was not
six seconds ago eight seconds piece is back he's
missed the technique and bought his pieces back
but he's still winning oh he dropped the rook look
the rook andrew and ferocia let me go real quick i
know we have a lot of games going on but i want
to show real quick something on move 30 that we
all missed why was this a blunder it wasn't taking
the queen there was something else oh can you take
on a4 we take on a four yeah and then we need a
bishop that's the one gg ggo as they would say
quickly and missed that tactic nakamura only one
point up by the way now there this key holding the
one point gap well this one is also only one
point gap we have some very exciting matches
going on very competitive indeed this is what
we expect to see in the finals and here we have
this game this is farouza versus andrew
tang andrew needs another win somehow
another win and i'm liking this position for white
i'm like oh you have to play g5 that is coming in
lee the f5 square is going to be forever the h5
square your bishop is terrible this is awful and
a sack on g5 let's go opening up the position you
couldn't take that piece or you'd be crushed and
now it's it's even horrible here you're getting
roasted on the squares oh my goodness here comes
a rook and the rooks are going to double on the h
line and rookie sixth threat check is threatened
you could just take because you cannot take
the knight oh it's the main one on a stick
the sacrifices all black pieces were on the other
side of the board you're at the wrong party buddy
you need to be over there to get it going let's
look at daniel versus darren ditki real quick
uh he carver just won his game it's up two points
seems like both are trying to get a two-point edge
only three minutes left i think we got our winners
must win no must-win game right now for the for
for andrew and dania it's not over yet it's not
over yet right now i mean it's basically over but
they have a [ __ ] that's a good position for
the last win game daniel has to win this game
in a position where he's down upon he's got
to win this game okay just got the pawn back
that's good got to figure out how to win
and and hikaru now defending like a beast
but look at that up up coupon up two pawns
it's gotta be i donated the pawn on two
still with a little bit of chance after f5
swing the rook and now a check and now he's up
upon again will he be able to maintain the pawn
though that knight on g7 does not promise much
and ikaro's pieces are more active yeah he's
gonna drag this out he's will drag this out
he just took the pawn and now he's ready for
mother he's great for a blunder it's a mate threat
got to play h4 and there's a pin so he got to get
out of the pin saw that coming and now can he find
a trick does danya he needs a trick of some kind
but the clock is clock times are my favorite it's
terrible i mean awful then he just oh he's gonna
lose that as well he needs he needs a miracle
we need a christmas miracle right now or darn is
going to go oh yeah 34. yeah thanks for watching
oh my goodness they're going too
bad now he just pulled the rook
oh no the match is over the match is over
let's quickly look at this one real quick
that hurt this is a must win for andrew and the
position says no down three pawns uh the clock
times alireza just needs to giddy up and this
should be easily done okay but he should try
to win because right now he's just trying
to play fast i think you should try to win
it's easy for him to push his pawns just
push yeah there should be an easy win
technique there we go he's pushing four
seconds ago four seconds this could be anything
three seconds left three seconds he's
going but you know what it doesn't matter
a draw wins it for him a draw he just cannot
lose win trade the rooks take the rules oh
even if he doesn't win wins for him and he does
win the game on time match is over he's through
as is nakamura it looks like nakamura has
done the do as well we have our two finalists
it's going to be ikaru nakamura and ala raza for
ruja upsetting andrew tang at least on the bullet
side he's much stronger in regular classical chess
but on the bullet side he's not as highly rated
he's done it what he's supposed to do by showing
he's a better chess player what a game man a lot
of games from both they both perform extremely
all of them have like 3400 bullet rating that is
insane to have here on chess.com and we
hear the thing it is over we have hikaru
versus ferocious as the final which is going to be
a great funnel uh as the players just play it out
uh for the last but down here ditschy and
andrew tang pick up a nice thousand dollars so
not a bad move for just a few few minutes of
chess yeah how can you complain i mean this
this was really good and we get a final a dream
final for ruja versus nakamura in the finals
that's a great that's a dream final if it's
bullet if it's classical if it's rapid if it's
in chess 960 i don't care if it was knots
and crosses this is a dream final to just
have those two amazing competitors two geniuses
play against each other so that's definitely
going to be a lot of fun right now andrew
tang looks like he's about to pick up a game
where just going to be irrelevant as he's winning
the night on e4 but nobody cares uh there's no
consolation prize for winning the last game
after you lost the match and so this is over yeah
this is going to be over uh probably it's going
to be a draw now because these things have yeah
yeah the razer actually has come back and
now it doesn't look like there's any wind oh
there we go so when eventually uh uh he's played
g4 this is this is uh not actually oh no no chance
no chance no it should be it should be drawn i
think he wants to win there's sir dominance uh but
this should be enough no the pawn is going to fall
and it is a draw we have our finalists we have
nakamura versus ali raza ferocia the iranian
wonder kids it's gonna be a really good one
it is it is it's it's going to be uh a hot
matchup but hikaru we we knew he was a beast
andrew showed he could get close but not enough
against a player of for rouge's ability level what
you saw there was just great chess ability now
we we have this i'm not going to make up a word
bullet ability right you you could have strong
bullet ability but when i combine the speed
with the strength of the moves then you get people
like hikaru you get people like ali raza i'm sure
andrew tank spanks most people when he's sitting
in front of them with his speed and he intimidates
them but when he's got to see good moves kind
of coming at him some strong 27 50 moves that
alareza dropped on him what about this what about
this answer this question you can play as fast as
you like 30 seconds in i got the better opening
i got the better middle game i got the better end
game technique oh you're playing really fast but
i got the winning position with 20 seconds left
i can handle myself that's what he faced it was
too much of a heavyweight battle for him to handle
and that was it i'll erase this through i'll
raise this through we have one more game and we
will interview the winner or the winner and loser
i'm not quite sure we're gonna see probably just
the winner so we'll see what's gonna go up we're
gonna go on the final quick break we're not gonna
say final quick wait we're all going on a quick
break and we'll be back with the final it's going
so fast maurice with the final of the bold open
chess championship see you guys in just a bit
and we are back for the final match
ladies and gentlemen hikaru nakamura
will be playing alibrazier for russia let's
just jump right in to the scene that has them
here we go we got ikara nakamura and
eraser racer looking a bit he's looking
chill they're both looking chill they're
both looking good they are ready to party
yes and alireza just needs to figure out
the whole camera thing obviously hikaru is
probably in a tsm studio right now so he's got the
whole set up so everything looks clean and nice
alireza has us in the interrogation room this
is when you've committed a crime and they've got
the lights on you in it and alireza's looking at
you and saying just confess just confess it it'll
be easier on you if you just confess so he's
got he's got to get a different look for sure
but it doesn't matter because he's got the moves
indeed he got the moves like jagger we will see
if he can get it done and many people are saying
this is a future world champion we're looking at
this is a future world champion he's going to
be playing magnus maybe in four or five years
but right now hikar was saying but
it's today it's today exactly future
is not now okay let's get it done and the man
right now in bullet is clearly hikaru nakamura i
do like uh that idea that if eli razor wins we'll
interview him as the good cop bad cop uh maurice
i think that's a brilliant idea that we got going
on with the lights uh but the games are about to
start no scratch that the games have started
hikaru not starting with b3 uh i am perplexed
let me tell you he knows he's playing it's a
very good player he can't mess around at all
and there's going to be some preparation on the
part of alareza because he's guessing that he's
playing against nakamura remember they've played
before they play on the magnus carlsen tour they
know each other they he knows how strong ali raza
is does nakamura so he's not going to mess around
against this young g so we are going to see
some good chess and already we're seeing a
kind of technical type positions appear on the
board as hikaru is worse here no question about
it black has a beautiful bishop in comparison
and the dominant on the c line but here goes b3
smart move this is going to make the game a
lot easier to defend for white and that's the
great thing about hikaru is his defensive
skills but i didn't like what alareza just
did right there he left the c file he refused
to give up his advantage and left the c file
oh he lost the bishop blundered me just blundered
mate you see there he really didn't want to
concede the win because he didn't want to give
him the c file it just didn't think it was enough
and he gave nakamura the c file and it bit him on
the rear end at the end of the game unbelievable
that is detrimental especially from a very that's
the thing with nakamura it's like a very stable
position there is no action bam he's on to
you give me your palms worse than that i call
nakamura hydra you try to chop off one head in the
position and two more grow he's simply he's just
astonishing defender he is so tenacious when he's
losing and the worst part is he's thinking about
winning when he's losing he's thinking about
winning the game he doesn't want to give you
a draw he's going to defend like a beast and then
he's going to come back and he's going to win the
game and then he's going to demoralize you when he
does that look at this position again ali raza out
playing in nakamura beautiful position someone got
a sack on g6 he's got a second g6 100 begging to
happen look at the dark square domination this
position is ugly i mean fugly is another word
you could use there i won't describe for you
what that means how does he break through ali
race is trying to figure it out he wants a sack
he's going to take him h5 he could take on g6
the pin was on oh my goodness he missed it and now
he's definitely being able to take on jesus take
an h5 i can take an h5 okay take it on h5 look at
yourself something is dangerous on the h line for
white how does he push through h5 and and some
kind of he could have called f6 it would have
been over the moment again there he goes and this
is a mating attack let's go this is winning he
better not lose this one this is the queen of six
lock it up well no you're right you're right over
right would have done that he would have made it
his life easy but now he's definitely no he's he's
made his life complicated he's given up he's one
of them oh that's a nice move e60 he's up a full
rook with eight seconds on the clock i don't care
how fast nakamura is he's not going to be able to
hold off in this position he's definitely going
to lose can't make it there we go and then it's
back both games he got outplayed nakamura but
there were some misses there for ali raisin
got to get himself tight so that he could
take advantage of those opportunities
that was very rare that we saw multiple multiple
misses one after the other and body still won so
the the way he played in the opening was just
so detrimental to icarus play that he did win
that game but now we're going to see here when you
mentioned hydra i thought you were a marvel fans
movie we're talking about i'm not sure if you know
that my hydra is like the secret organization we
make uh hikaru the antagonist we have razor the
protagonist i'm a classical guy i'm a classical
guy you know i i'm an english major we go back to
the classical descriptions i you know you young
g's remember stuff like like that or know stuff
like that that i don't know but there here we go
this is crushing right now for ikaru this is the
thing about him as well when we say hydra all
right you beat him and you think i got him look
what i'm doing i got hit car who he's messing up
guess what you're resigning the next game that's
what's happening that's how he is he doesn't get
frazzled he could go down two and he's gonna win
five i mean that's just the nature of this beast
and interestingly we have seen the same
opening three times in a row now from both ends
so let's see what's going to happen again yeah
there's going to be an attack on the king side
i'm not sure if i specifically liked it but ikaro
probably found out where the flaw was and he's
going to defend it properly this time yeah the
problem was he took on e5 and a lot of complete
domination after the pawn took and caused a dark
square weaknesses permanently in his position
this is not so rosy either by the way he's got
a weakness on e6 and alireza is going to pound
at it he's going to double on the d the e line
and eventually he's going to play for the move
d5 so nakamura has to be watchful and also
by the way the move h5 is going to come
at the right moment and that's going to cause some
challenges as well so here this is an interesting
exchange of pawns i didn't like the trade of
queens i would have kept the pieces on the board
and but the knight on f3 is really well placed
i would have liked to play g5 as well but still
this position is looking okay for white i'm
like white with the looks double on the seventh
that was really good for right ninety
five oh he could have won the pc
these games that you're supposed to win he
missed a straight win of a piece but his h
pawn is talking his h pawn is barking right now
so that's a challenge for nakamura nakamura has
decided to get rid of it oh he's trying to play
this position where he's down a knight but he's
got some a passer this is winning though why the
f i'm about to say why aren't you pushing your f
pawn just push him uh defend that and the knight
will be able to go to the f57 push it again push
it again just push it again this is easy and now
it's all about stopping the play for black but
it was a sneaky trick one little trick queen on
the board ali raza bouncing back we have a wow
going on right now folks this is good two to two
let's go two and a half minutes left on the clock
i don't care who wins but i want a sudden death
maurice i want to jump out of my chair i want
to jump in and out of my chair for something
happening let's go i'm going to tell you that
white has won every game so far why that's true
every single game all right this is just hitting
hit and hit back hit and hit back that's how we
like the heavyweight matches but somebody has
to save the position with black and alert has
played this variation where it looked like he
was dropping a pawn but he got it right back in
the sicilian there's a good position for black a
great position for black so he just needs to keep
it equal i don't like that move queen beat though
and the threats are on and now the queen side is
collapsing oh what's your favorite rook oh bishop
of free bishop f3 nasty and you're losing a piece
that was not well played by the youngster there
the bet the retreating moves is kind of crowding
in on his own self and white wins yet again
nakamura is up again i mean i get uh raising knows
i'm black so i'm gonna lose anyway might as well
grab the white pieces and uh and punch through
that way so let's see how that's gonna go out
uh f4 or five designation but the way he played
that with his last position was just unacceptable
it was unacceptable that you just can't do
that you just can't do that and now knight
g4 with the knight landing on e3 c2 is hanging
and he's got to take on f5 just do it like g4
okay okay he is he won material but it's not very
spicy what do we have here f6 nakamura allowed f6
and suddenly he's sitting up in his chair
realizing that his that side of the board is
collapsing uh do you take it good question no
we move this king over and g5 rook g1 is what
he's hoping for but the king's going to escape to
h5 wait what is this you getting out h4 go for h6
oh that would have been that would
have been something yeah you're right
but knight g5 crash boom he's through he's
gonna let's go this is a mating attack for real
this is good stuff right now but nakamura
has to keep his cool he's taken and he's
and he's running he's on his high horse and
everybody's dropping look at all those pros
he could take on he could take on d5 with check
and the problem is now he has no attack he's
got to turn the game around he's just giving up
his bishop and he's giving what's going on here
but he couldn't figure out what to do and he lost
the game the first loss for white in the match
nakamura takes it with the black pieces that was
nasty that steal that was nasty that is nasty and
we will see a lot of stalling this time because
we only have five and a half minutes left maurice
and a two point gap which means carl's gonna
take things slow if he's in the losing position
that that was a big time win let me tell you big
time win for hikaru to get a game where he was
just lost he was just simply lost and now farouza
is in a must-win situation i'm going to tell it
to you right now farouza must win this game and
it's not looking good for him he must win this
game if he doesn't win this game the match is
over that's my bet if he doesn't win this game
the match is simply over and i think that last
loss may be the decider but he must win this game
in front of us right now and he has his chances
great night on c4 but he's got to figure it out
because the pawn the knight on d4 is also quite
strong so not easy to hold or to try to get any
chances maggie two free pawn no it's not it's not
i mean what is this move definitely one knight
f1 check idea there was a there's a queenie
one but naka is trying to make sure there's a
queen deal and he noticed what to do all right
now now he gets at least a draw but he hasn't
but he doesn't and now nakamura
playing check you got to move over
naka is just torturing him now because he can't
figure out wait a minute is it what do we have it
looks like both of them are losing it looks like
both of them are losing i couldn't know but i know
ellie raises losing on time he's gonna move fast
he has only seven seconds left but that bla that
white king looks terrible but how do you get at
it this is not gonna be the way to get at it nope
that didn't do it and he's now officially losing
the match he's going to lose the match this is
over he is totally dead and that game he lost the
last game was the decider because look at the car
he's bumping he's going let's go yeah he's
feeling it now he knows the match is over
that was a big win it's only three minutes
left so essentially only two games remaining
ali raza could not have afforded to lose that
last not this game that just passed but the one
before it because that cost him this game as well
and now he's in deep trouble he's not going to be
able to win fast enough and he's going for it he's
just going for it with this move he's just saying
i'm just going to go for it i'm giving up a rook
it doesn't matter i just want to get some kind of
attack going and try to win quickly knocker could
sit here for a while he's played a very risky
move in g5 and his kick wow look at that king
he's uh he's tackling g5 here bishop takes g5
and knight he's 95 was not the one was not
what about bishop g6 there if he took him
now the guy's gonna have enough time uh queen
f8 was coming this is over this is over the
match is over he car is gonna win this match
we're we're just looking to see whether or not
farouja can somehow win a game and keep it
respectable but now d5 on the board and naca
is feeling himself absolutely he's up a whole
rook with no attack to speak on nothing here it
is all black black to win he's going to
win this game there is a resignation in
and the route is on hikaru nakamura as
predicted showing why he's the best in the world
absolutely there was a i think about bishop
g6 that would have been a cute tactic but
let's keep on this game as it is there's only
two look at him he's going bananas you don't
know what he takes but i want some of that as
well he's the number one street chess streamer
in the world he's also one of the greatest
competitors we've ever seen look at this
look at what he's just done queen got
attacked and he look at him he's partying now
he's partying he's playing to the crowd he's
playing to the crowd he has his fans and look at
him he's waving it up i mean he may not be able to
dance but he's dancing all over perugia right now
i mean he's like yo yo what's up what's up i am
killing this youngster you you're maybe the future
son but i'm the president and i'm going to show
you how it's done and look at him partying like
it's 1999 1999 just about to say perfect yeah just
enjoying this advent major edge in this position
just winning now to bring the king over and
it's going to be over look at that g3 technique
your king is stuck just move your king back
and forth my king is coming over here right now
he can do that there's nothing he can do the
king's just coming over then the king's coming up
then the king's going up some more uh well you
can't draw you can't afford to draw the game
that's that's that's definitely resignation
so in cairo just playing it out taking a look
i'm not sure exactly how he wins though
there must be a winning idea here what is wow
do you know how you could have won you know how
you should have won i should do well he should
have played king a3 after before check that was
the thing remember before checking play king a3
and then his king just marches up the board
that's what he should have done so he can't
miss that idea at the end there but you know what
he's not missed much today he's up four games
with only 20 seconds left folks it's the party
hour for hikaru as he's gonna be able to stream
he's streaming now but he's all his fans are
watching him prove why he's so dominant this
is why they love him because he just gets it done
when it's time to get it done absolutely he knew
it was time to boogie and he's showing that as
well with g4 very aggressive rook only move rook
takes d3 yeah seems like the only move and yes
and good only and good is there a way to to just
figure you know just when you think you might have
a power rule he says you can have whatever you
like go ahead take whatever you like we're ju and
now a sacrifice okay that looks like a good sack
you might have to take it and play bishop
g7 uh that looks like uh not a first mate
as he's allowed and now fuji six queen g6
knight is even sexier i like it i like it sexier
that would have been nice no queen g6 is
real g5 queen g6 is rook g5 excuse me you
retray it off and then it's still queen
96 mate no because there's a pawn on f7
oh you're correct you're right no you're right
you have to try to win material with knight g6
and then take oh he still doesn't though
did he think we were busy talking about it
the rook left that's what happened the
rook left f5 and went to f4 and he got
it but naka is like so what i'm i won three
congratulations for the most spectacular move
of the match but i'll take the 10k that's what
he says congrats on your move i'll take the 5k
that's for me we're going to get him on interview
so we're going to go on a really short break
chat don't go anywhere we'll be back with grand
master hikaru nakamura see you guys just a bit
so
and welcome back everyone to the
bullet open championship we are here
in the presence of legends uh was already
maurice actually now also he coroner kimura
and alaris of russia uh hikaru i saw you were
dancing how are you feeling i mean it it was
just a very ten it was very tense and actually
i thought i mean when i won a couple of games
it was nice to relax the end so um yeah it was a
tough match but i found a way so i'm pretty happy
alareza it looked like you had a good chance in
the very beginning and you're sorry in the opening
game we were doing well and it looks like hikaru
stole that game you were able to bounce back once
and then it was back and forth heavyweight action
what was your feeling do you think that you you
could have possibly taken the lead early and did
that disturb you at all when he was able to play
such masterful defense to stop you yeah i mean
when we played the first four games i understood
my black openings are just awful in this match
so i knew that i should play very good with white
and i really didn't know how to like improve
it so that was the main problem i think and
yeah okay that game that i didn't win it was
it was a good defense of course by color but
in general i think um the black opening was my
problem yeah we noticed that i think white formed
five times in a row white was definitely the
favorites to uh to go in ikaru uh you had a very
good start uh some hard opposition how do you feel
about your first games going against uh danielski
i mean i think basically because the the
format was so short with 15 minutes like at
the very start i mean it's super critical the
first probably two games decide i think most
matches um and yeah i thought against dania um it
was very very tense with some back and forth also
um but i think the most important thing is that
i didn't lose a game like the first game in any
of the match i think that actually was was
very very important because it was always
uh like especially the final match i would win a
game then ollie russell would win and i would win
so it was always it was always after my win he
would have to win again with white and i think
it's very hard when you have to keep winning
um winning every game with white especially
what do you need to do you think
alyreza given this challenge
it seems like nakamura always rises to the
occasion just just rising rising especially
in bullet looks like everybody on the planet is
terrified when naka is sitting across from them in
bullet what do you need to do to break this spell
to make it seem like somebody can beat this guy
of course hikaru has a very good experience i
learned a lot from him when i played bullets so
i i still expect that then i could have done
better but like me losing to a car is nothing like
um some crazy things so and of course
i think i could improve more in bullets
when i could maybe a little older but now i
think i played my like on the best today so
absolutely uh for roger you played extraordinary
today it was a very tense match against
uh was andrew again or jeffrey shung i think you
played entertain there uh very tense match anyway
uh i'm out of questions maurice you want to shoot
one absolutely i want to congratulate ricardo once
again i mean you were my pick to win this whole
thing you delivered once more you're feeling
as you're streaming and playing bullet you're
talking you look like you're having so much fun
is that the truth you're having such a good time
doing all this you look like you're on top of the
world right now yeah i mean i think it's it's a
lot of fun when you can play i mean i think the
fact that there's so many people who are watching
chess whether it's my channel whether it's
chess.com channel um that that certainly uh gives
me a lot of motivation i really do enjoy it so
i mean it's all about the fans i mean they're the
reason that we play at least online for sure so
i'm just grateful there's so many people who
love the game of chess that's really what it
comes down to and that that really does give me
the motivation i think more than anything else
well keep doing what you do great job great work
and alareza we know you're the future you say
a little older i'm thinking a little older like
six months because you're growing before our eyes
congratulations to you both for making it this
far and finally again congrats to karu for having
a spectacular result thank you you guys have a
good thank you yeah thank you guys we're going
to hit you with the raid after this again hikar
congratulations alireza let's hope you start a
stream as well i know you're on twitch so we might
as well get some bullet matches late night on the
twitch stream as well so thank you guys so much
for being here and have a have a great stream
see you guys thank you all right let's look at
the final bracket for the final time he did have a
tough start against andrew tang ali razor but he
did come back really really well i went five and
a half two and a half and it's always ten steffi
caro there because he's such a legend maurice and
uh that was that was a good match nice ending
match went back and forth we had some jobs
we had some bug we had some gangsters in
the position especially when we had that
king side attack um that was a great event
well it all came down to that one game
i think it was game six where ali raza was hunting
with the white pieces trying to even up again
as nakamura said it's hard when you get hit you
hit back he hits you again you hit back and he
hits you again there's three times you got hit the
pressure's on you must deliver in that next game
and unfortunately he was winning he was winning
but how many times have we heard that against
hikaru nakamura ikaru stole that game and once
he grabbed that game and took a two-point lead
that was it that was all she wrote icarus shows
why he is such a beast in these competitions at
bullet chess and he's having a good time and
like i said to him it's lovely it's amazing
what he's doing for chess with his streams people
following in a big way people loving it certainly
just forging ahead for those of us who stream
like myself i just came into this streaming world
in in october i mean maybe september october
so i'm still at the very beginning but hikaru
is somebody we all look up to is getting it done
showing what chess can do he's powering ahead and
he's doing it not only with with flash he's doing
it because he's a champion exactly and i think
what the one thing i've learned today maurice is
when the chorus starts dancing you know it's over
you know it's done it's over it's over it's over
all right so we're going to raise carl make sure
to follow maurice astley twitch.the v slash game
ashley you can see it under here he streams at
5 00 p.m eastern time tomorrow am i correct
that's right around that time let's give her
more or less or less i'll be preparing a lot of
good stuff for tomorrow so you know my streams
are all about instruction i want fans to learn
not just be entertained but to learn some stuff
about chess i always bring some new ideas to the
table of course there's also the gangsters gangsta
chess edition we got that segment of the show
so you're gonna see some good chess somebody's
gonna get hurt uh in the games always bring that
fire as well so we're we're gonna have some fun
tomorrow absolutely and there's no instructional
might on my end of the stream but there is a puppy
you see my puppy maurice that is a reason to
follow you gotta keep too sure she's cute royce
it's been an absolute pleasure thank you so much
you've been amazing at this commentary and you'll
be back here anytime i know that i'll probably
be behind doing the production so former race
ashley this is about too big and we're gonna hit
the caro and thank you guys so much for watching
make sure to follow us especially maurice and we
will see you in the next event good night everyone
you